hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to another round of me
being roasted by the internet I went on
our roast me about a year and a half ago
or maybe even more than that now maybe
almost two years ago now I went on our
roast meat and Here I am back again for
another round of punishment because it
wasn't that bad I didn't cry for that
long I got a little more self confidence
in me that I need to stomp out and in
fact on my birthday I actually made
these posts and I asked people to roast
me again so let's see what you got in
store for me and if I'm gonna cry like a
little [ __ ] baby here see if you even
look on the roast meat page I'm actually
kind of Mike Wazowski get up over here
hidden up by the smooth oh good selleth
celebrity auditory cancer great I'm
sorry but no matter how far you stretch
that log of a neck you still 6 feet tall
guess I guess I was stretching a bit in
this pic here and no matter his eyes
they will never look if this roast me
says anything about your career then
you're truly not relevant anymore
you couldn't even manage to make this to
the front page I don't think I made it
to the front page last time anyway but I
definitely made it to the front page of
your subreddit so maybe it's your
subreddit is dying no it's me might I
add I'm here twice so I'm like the hero
of this subreddit or the villain or the
piece of [ __ ] standing the corner hidden
behind this new Hasbro have already
issued a cease and desist for the
unauthorized use of a mr. Potato Head
fruits how do they know we're hangin I
gotta pull up a side-by-side of that one
here we go
everything's gonna be worth it don't
look away
[Music]
is oddly striking your channel taught me
the desirability of no commentary
gameplay videos I wouldn't unplug your
life support to charge my phone I would
just unplug it your life support I get
it
I think you know know who likes him when
his own dick says things about him I
didn't even see that that guy's name was
Mark a Blair's dick what at what we're
just gonna ignore the fact that his dick
owns a phone his dick is its own
sentient being my dick has its own
channel over on pornhub stop calling up
PewDiePie for video ideas no his service
is so affordable he's desperate for
money
none of his videos get monetized so I
have to go to him
your girlfriend only stays with you for
your bank account and your dog mostly
the dog I say that pretty much anyone in
my life only sticks around because she
goes do cute I could literally I can
literally be replaced with chica
tomorrow and no one would care in fact
everyone would be happier wouldn't give
this signal dislike everything would be
lovely hey wait no this is this seems
familiar
you look like markiplier it could be
worse he could behave markiplier it's
deja vu all of please tell me there's
links to the first one no offense but
I'm sorry but I think he posted to the
wrong sub read you should know this [ __ ]
is but from reading the comments he
seems to maybe be a youtuber hey didn't
you read from my quote-unquote celebrity
tag I am auditory cancer sir kited screw
what the other guys have said your
content really moves me for example my
eight-year-old brother was watching one
of your videos so I moved to a different
room
ah [ __ ] you are to YouTube what Amy
Schumer is to comedy I got a response to
that one that's pretty good my little
sister loves this guy probably because
he looks and acts like a sock puppet
come to life yeah shoved up my ass every
video novel over here you're the one of
the worst things about YouTube your
content so bad the shitty games live
action's lamb ripping off game grumps
find me B Permian or stop dyeing your
hair like a 15 year old lesbian Lin
crying videos no engage twelve-year-old
audience you're good but then more than
even came close to roasting me because
the next comment is okay biography over
now roast him yeah good job at wasting
everybody's time their mark please tone
down the resolution of your image it's
hard enough to look at your face in 720p
without vomiting the less pixels the
better I'd rather [ __ ] Wade and then the
next guy real original like Marga
Blair's videos ah two and one roasting I
fizzle burned you should start putting
your content on pornhub you'll fit in
there perfectly with all the exaggerated
screaming and close-up shots of [ __ ]
you're my college dropout inspiration
thank you I'm happy I can inspire you
dude
scroll through the read it doodlee do
she's mark blocker doodly-doo closes
ready oh boy
you should call your mom and apologize
is a really disappointing date for her
too oh my mom reminds me about the day I
was born
every birthday ruined her and I was
never supposed to be poor at least you
don't look as bad as this guy cuz it
better be good picture so anyway that is
all the time I got for this video thank
you everybody so much for watching and
thank you to everybody that took the
time
to roast me I really do appreciate it
like believe it or not I really do
appreciate it because a lot of you guys
took the time to craft up some jokes or
maybe you recycled them from your old
roast I don't really care this was a lot
of fun and if you guys watching have a
roast of your own and maybe you think
you can do better than these guys over
on this subreddit then let me have it
come on make me laugh try insult me I
don't care put it down in the comments
below
vote up the ones that make you laugh and
if you're just tossing out an insult fat
feel free I don't really care but let's
see what you got cuz it doesn't matter
to me if you guys roast me if people
hate me like it really doesn't all that
matters is it I'm having a great time
making videos and trying to make myself
better that's all it's all about that's
what it's all about so thank you again
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye